[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم انتقد وزير الخارجيه المصري
المؤقت نبيل فهمي موقف المجتمع الدولي مما
يجري في مصر وقال ان حكومته ترفض اي
محاوله ل تدويل الازمه المصريه اضاف فهم
انه يرفض اي تلويح بوقف المساعدات
الاجنبيه في ظل الظرف الحالي نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لنناقشه في محورين
ما هي مرتكزات رؤيه السلطه الحاليه في مصر
لعلاقاتها بالعالم في ضوء تصريحات وزير
خارجيتها
وكيف يبدو مستقبل علاقات مصر الخارجيه وفق
رؤيه السلطه الحاكمه للتعاطي مع الخارج
في اعقاب سلسله ادانات دوليه تلقتها
السلطات الحاكمه في مصر على خلفيه تعاملها
مع معارضي الانقلاب قالت القاهره انها
ستطلق حمله دبلوماسيه لتوضيح ما يجري في
مصر للخارج الذي بدا من وجهه نظرها غير
ملم بحقيقه الاحداث طالما انه يواصل حثها
على ضروره تجنب العنف من دون ان يوجه
نصيحه مماثله لما تسميه الطرف الاخر في
اطار هذه الحمله فيما يبدو عقد وزير
الخارجيه المؤقت نبيل فهمي مؤتمرا صحفيا
تضاربت التقديرات بشان نجاعته لجهه خدمته
الغرض الذي عقد من اجله
مصر كلها على مفترق الطرق سياسه البلاد
الخارجيه على المحك في ضوء الاحداث
الداميه والانتقادات الدوليه الواسعه
لتعامل السلطه الحاكمه مع معارضيها وزير
الخارجيه مؤقت نبيل فهمي انتقد بشده مواقف
المجتمع الدولي رافضا التلويح بوقف
المساعدات لمصر متهما الدول التي ابدت
اعتراضها على الاسلوب الامني بانها تنظر
للاحداث بعين واحده وتركز فقط على مطالبه
السلطات المصريه وتغض الطرف عن الجانب
الاخر الذي ح تمت ممارساته على الحكومه
التحرك بالشكل الذي تم على حد قوله
وما فتيات القاهره تلقى انتقادات دوليه
واقليميه واسعه بسبب الاجراءات التي
تتبعها مع معارضين انقلاب الثالث من يوليو
وبين انعكاساتها الموقف الامريكي وتبادل
استدعاء السفراء مع تركيا وما تردد عن وقف
شركات كبرى اعمالها في مصر اضافه الى
خسائر البورصه الواضحه وما يشبه الشلل في
الحركه السياحيه اخر الانتقادات حمل فيها
رئيس الاتحاد الاوروبي ورئيس المفوضيه
الاوروبيه الجيش والحكومه المؤقته مسؤوليه
عوده الهدوء للبلاد وحذر من ان الاتحاد
سيعيد النظر في علاقاته مع مصر اذا لم
يتوقف العنف ويحتكم للحوار واعتبر المسؤول
ان ان اي زياده في التصعيد يمكن ان تحدث
عواقب غير متوقعه على مصر والمنطقه وفي
هذه الاثناء ومهما كانت نتائج حمله
العلاقات العامه التي اعلن ان الحكومه
ستوضع خلالها الصوره الحقيقيه للاحداث
الراهنه ومهما كانت نتائج المراجعه التي
امر وزير الخارجيه باجرائها على المساعدات
التي تلقاها مصرف ان السلطه الحاليه في
البلاد تبقى في موقف المدافع داخليا
وخارجيا
ولو الى حين ويبدو ان منطق الوزير المصري
يستند على قاعده خير وسيله للدفاع هي
الهجوم
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفنا في
الاستوديو الدكتور محمد زكريا مطر الاستاذ
الجامعي والعضو في جبهه الدم الضمير
الوطنى المصرى ومن واشنطن معنا نبيل
ميخائيل استاذ العلوم السياسيه بجامعه
جورج تاون اهلا بكما دكتور محمد نبدا من
عندك يعني واضح ان وزير الخارجيه المصري
من المواقف الدوليه التي اطلقت في الايام
الماضيه اه اتجاه ما يجري في مصر هل اقنع
في اه الحجج التي ساقها في المؤتمر الصحفي
اه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم دعيني اولا
اترحم على الشهداء الذين قتلوا غدرا في
مصر واخرهم ثمانيه وثلاثين واحد تم
تصفيتهم من الانقلابيين الذين
اساؤوا لمصر واساء والى العالم الحر حتى
لا يضيع الوقت
هذا الوزير الانقلاب يستاثر واه اه لا
الكتله اعلامي انه هو عميد كليه الالباب
ليك بوليس في الجامعه الامريكيه في مصر
ومعرفش اوصلها عميد يزيدون ان يكون فيه
الا اذا كنت شويه فهو اصلا مع الامريكان
هو بيدل على الامريكان وب يستاثر عليهم ان
امام الشعب المصري يريد ان العالم الحر
الديمقراطي
لا يدري انه هو بخط بصعوبه وانه له
تقديراته للموقف يريد ان يرى مصر من خلال
عن وزير الخارجيه وهذا خطا خطا تجاوزه
لكنه ساقه الكثير من الحجاج الدكتور محمد
يعني قال ان المجتمع الدولي ينظر بعين
واحده الى ما يجري في مصر اه اه ينتقد
الاجراءات الحكوميه من دون ان ينتقد
اجراءات الطرف الاخر وقال ان دولا اخرى
واجهت ما تواجهه مصر اليوم اه حقيقه انه
كل ما عرض من هزيمه في
ثلاثين يونيو بالفوتوشوب تاخذ صلاح هذا
نظام انقلابى كاذب كل ما عرضوا عندما يقول
ويعرض واقول لك اخوان المسلمين الاخوان
المسلمين هل معلقين نمر انه يقول الاخوان
هذا النظام يدخل البلطجيه و لقد رايت هم
البلطجيه في مسجد الفتح الذين تجنبهم
الحكومه ويدخلون في المظاهرات لاثاره
الشغب حتى علم القاعده الذي كان ما قلت
كانت تحرص الحكومه للاساءه هذا النظام
الامني اذا تذكرنا كريست القديم كل هذه
ادله مفبركه غير صادقه والعالم يدري ذلك
نريد ان نرى كيف يقتل انا عندي بيان الان
اكثر من خمسه الاف شهيد قتلوا وحرقوا في
سابقه لم تحدث في تاريخ مصر في العشره
الاف سنه اطلاقا كيف
في العالم ما يرون حرق
وجهات نظر اه اه النبيل ميخائيل
في واشنطن استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
جورج تاون اه استاذ نبيل اه هل اقنعت وزير
الخارجيه بما ساقه وان يكفي مجرد ان يرفض
هو هذه المواقف الدوليه اه يعني الكثيره
التي صدرت في الايام الماضيه اتجاه ما
يجري في مصر وشجبت ه وادانت لكي تتغير هذه
المواقف
فيها حجه لكن الامور بتاخذ مسار مهم
النداء قبل اوباما اوباما يخسر في مصر
بمعنى ان هناك انتخاب كثير لاوباما بانه
الاحداث العنيف اللي حصلت في مصر هي ايضا
مسؤوليته لعله لم يتخذ موقف بشان هذا
القطر او هذه الدوله امامنا ولكن
تنطلق في مواقفها مما يجري اه وفق شعبيتها
في الشارع المصري
لا طبعا معلوماتها عن الموقف ضئيله جدا
اوباما بوجود عمليه يركب عدم يعني حاجه
ماسه خالص دا مش واحد يعني رجل دوله عالمي
اه ف في عدم اهتمام في استهتار فعلا
اوباما يحدد اما انه يؤيد الاسلاميين
القوات المسلحه
الاثنين
وموقف الولايات المتحده لكن هناك الكثير
من الدول لديك الاتحاد الاوروبي الذي يوم
اه اه اصدر يعني حذر من انه سيعيد النظر
في علاقاته مع مصر اذا لم يتوقف العنف
بطبيعه الحال لديك ايضا الولايات المتحده
لديك دول اخرى عديده يعني لا مجال للذكر
اه اه ذكرها وتعداد كل ال اه اه المواقف
ولكن ربما تعرفها واطلعت عليها كما اه
باقي المشاهدين في الصحافه ايضا يعني اه
كيف هل ما يقوله وزير الخارجيه وحده هو
كاس لتغيير كل هذه النظره الى ما يجري في
مصر
اعاده النظر من قبل الاوروبيين مش
الاستراتيجيه الغابه مش استراتيجيه امريكا
اه هي ما تحدد مصير العالم وعلاقته مع
الاوروبيين مش حياخد ومواقف من عزله عن
امريكا دي حاجه مهمه اه لكن لو انت امام
بتطالب بمصالحه وطنيه
اه من الواضح ان جيش اكثر في الشارع لانه
ح يستخدم العنف ضد الاخوان في مصالحه
وطنيه بتصدر من واشنطن حتبقى يعني من قبل
او بشروط القوات المسلحه وبعدين كمان
الاخوان بيستخدموا العنف
الطالب بحرب اوباما الطالب اشراك الاخوان
او الاسلاميين في عمليه المصالحه وهما مش
قوات ديمقراطيه خالصه لوجه الله بيستخدموا
العنف في اي مسؤول المصري سواء نبيل فهمي
او غيره لم يخاطب اوباما وامريكا والبيت
الابيض والعالم حتكون العوامل على
الموقف الامريكي اه يعني اكرر السؤال
بطريقه اخرى اليوم من هي الدول التي تدعم
مصر فيما تفعله اه اه في الداخل واتجاه
هذا العنف الذين راس الشارع
لو يعني
خمسمائه وخلاص مع روسيا الصين الى حد ما
غيرت مواقفها مهمه عشان ما تنير الامارات
السعوديه الكويت
الاوروبيين وعمر خذوا موقف اتجاه
بحاجه
مواقف امريكا محمد
هناك دول اه اه لا تتغير مواقفها اسيا
تغير موقفها اه اسمحي لي خمس دول فقط التي
اعترفت بالانقلاب هناك اه شيء
الاعتبار حقيقه هو ان هذه الدول تحترم
نفسها امام شعوبها هي لا تخاطب وزير
الخارجيه المصري هي تخاطب شعوبها والشعوب
الحره اللي انتخبته انا في الحقيقه كما
قال المحاور من واشنطن انه ليست القضيه
بالاسلاميين وبين جيش القضيه بينما انا
لست من الاخوان انا بدافع عن حقه في
المسار الديمقراطي ما اكتشفت ثوره 25
يناير هذا هو الذي خرجت به الجماهير
والملايين في الشارع ليست المشكله بين
الاسلاميين كما يريد ان يصوروا هذا تزوير
ال ال ال ال الذي يدور في مصر هو صراع
ولكن نحن نتحدث عن اه اه البعد الخارجي في
هذا الموضوع البعد الخارجي لا اعتقد ذلك
عدم من الدول قال انه المصري لغير
اعتقد ان ما قاله اليوم وزير الخارجيه
وهذه الحمله الدبلوماسيه التي تقول مصر
انها ستقود ها ستؤدي في النهايه الى تغيير
الموقف وفق الرؤيه المصريه له لم يعترف
بالانقلاب غير
خمس دول الكويت منهم جولتين خليجي يتم
ترتعد خوفا من ثوره مصر وقدمت رشاوى
الكويت المعارضه الكويتيه اوقفت الاربعه
مليار لا اريد تصرفهم والباقي الرشوه التي
قدمت هذه ل لم تجدي نفعا بعض المشتقات
البتروليه الى اخره انا اريد ان ان ان ان
نوضح لك الموقف تماما لا لم يمكن للانقلاب
ان يتمادى في هذا الغي لولا دعم اسرائيليا
وامريكيا
لو لم يكن مدعوم اسرائيلي وامريكي ما كان
يمكن ان يستمر في هذا الفكر الذي يقوم به
اه هذه النقطه مهمه يجب ان تاخذ في
الاعتبار اما بالنسبه لامريكا اوباما
بيلعب خلف هو اوباما مش اللي يراقب مصر
ربما عنده اه سي اي ايه وعنده مراكز بحوث
وعنده اجهزه تقدم له تقارير وبياخذ على
اساسها هذا القرار اوباما يتصرف
تماما في اوضاع اذا ايدها سيفقد احترام
امام الشعب لا يمكن ان يبرر امام شعبه
خمسه الاف واحد وقتلهم غيره كيف كيف يمكن
ان يبرر امام شعب وساطه مسلح على السلطه
هذا كيف يمكن ان ان قائد الانقلاب حماس
باليمين نبيل عند اعداد دول تقول انها
دعمت او تدعم او تقف بجانب السلطات
المصريه الحاليه ربما هي خمس او ست دول
حتى الان هل يستطيع نظام جديد يقول انه اه
اه وفق حديث يعني اركان في هذا النظام
الجديد انه اه اه
يؤسس لدوله جديده ان يعتمد على اه اه دعم
هذه الدول فقط خمس دول في العالم كله
سؤال غلط لان اولا مش دوله جديده ثاني
حاجه انا يعني
اه اه اه جديد وانتقاله
خلاص في دور كثير من الحرمان اللي بيحصل
في مصر يعني لمنظمه الوحده الافريقيه فيها
خمسين دوله اه يعني بوتسوانا حتى مهمه اوي
وبعدين لما بقول روسيا وباقول الامارات
جديده ولا اعتقد مواقف تؤيد مصر يعني ممكن
تعارض امريكا اما لو ان تلقى على الموضوع
اوروبا معظم دول اوروبا بتزايد مصر يعني
حتى لو الدول الاوروبيه اعترضت على مصر مش
حال غياب الشارع المصري اللي حاصل هزيمه
للاخوان لا يعرفوا غيروا مواقف العالم ولا
اعرف يسيطر على الشارع المصري فبالتالي
اللي حتبقى
اللي حصل في مصر وخلاص كثير بس طبعا فيه
عوامل استراتيجيه تحصل او لها دور مهم
لروسيا في المنطقه واوباما مشدده هو ممكن
توصل تقارير بس مش خيرا هامش ناقشها
القضيه انه ممكن فعلا مصر اه تغير من مسار
العلاقات الدوليه الى حد ما مش بطريقه
راديكاليه او بطريقه كبيره بس من الواضح
ايضا انه في مصالحه وطنيه الاخوان مشاعر
يفرضوا شروطهم حتى لو كان فيه انتهاكات
لحقوق الانسان
ابقوا معنا ضيوفنا سنتابع نقاشنا اه بعد
فاصل قصير
نتحدث عن ملامح سياسه مصر الخارجيه في
الفتره المقبله حسب تصريحات وزير خارجيتها
فابقوا معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش ملامح علاقه سلطات مصر الحاليه مع
الخارج في ضوء تصريحات وزير الخارجيه
المصري المؤقت دكتور محمد زكريا مطر يعني
اه كما قال نبيل اسرائيل من واشنطن اه
هناك دول قد تغير رايها هناك دول قد لا
تغير رايها بعض الدول رايها اصلا غير مهم
اه ووزير الخارجيه فعليا بدا واثقا من
نفسه اه كثيرا حتى انه تتحدث عن انه سيتم
اعاده النظر في المساعدات التي تقدم اه
الى مصر يعني مصر تعيد النظر في المساعدات
التي تتلقاها كيف تقرا هذا الموضوع اه
ابسط شيء في في السياسه الدوليه هو
التعامل بين الدول يتم على اساس المنافع
المتبادله والقوه التي في دوله انا باسال
الذي استاثر لفظيا ماذا عنده يمكن ان
يقدموا او اه اه اه اه يعني اه اه يعني ما
هي عوامل القوه التي في يد هذا الوزير
لانه يقابل بها العالم هو ليس فيه هو
مستقبل المساعدات هو يستقبل المساعدات
واذا قطعوها عنه يعني مساله ال الم ال اه
يعني انا اريد ان اصل الى تفصيل المساعدات
في الحقيقه لان دي تفصلها يوضح الشيء احنا
الاتحاد الاوروبي مساعدات وحوالي اربعمائه
وخمسين مليون دولار يعني نقول في حدود
اثنين ونص مليار جنيه او حاجه زي كده
الامريك ابتدى واحد
يعني واحد وثلاثه من عشره مليون مساعده
عسكريه تذهب الى الجسم الجيش مباشره لا
تمر بالدوله ولذلك الجيش ياخذ مرتبته من
امريكا ومائتين وخمسين مليون اقتصادي او
مساعده اقتصاديه هذه المساعدات في الحقيقه
انا في برامج سابقه
يعني حقيقه
القوه يعني احنا لو وقفنا ال عمره سنتين
استغني عن المعونه الامريكيه يعني في
اشياء كثيره ممكن لو
سفارتنا في الخارج خلصنا ها نحن نوفر انما
المشكله ليس هناك نيه فهو ليس فيها اي نوع
من عوامل القوه التي يتكلم على اساسها
ليس عنده وهو رجل
احنا بنسميه المصري انقلبوا كويس
ما هي عوامل القوه يسالك محمد زكريا التي
يمتلكها وزيرها الخارجيه حتى يلوح بقطع
هذه المعونات التي ترد الى مصر
مش سميها ملامح القوه او يحاول انه هو
نظام محافظ يملك عده اوراق وحركه على نقطه
محافظ فهو يسعى الى الاستقرار اه علشان
كده مش صحيح او للغايه العلاقه مع امريكا
باسلوب جذري فالى لقبها تستمر حتى لو فيه
اصوات معترضه من داخل صفوف اداره اوباما
من داخل البيت الابيض او حتى من الكونغرس
لكن فيه يعني عوامل استراتيجيه جديده يعني
مثلا علاقه مع ايران مشهد تتاثر اوي اه اه
علاقه مصر مع روسيا بتقوى له علاقه مصر
وايران قويه مع وجود دور روسيا يبقى نصف
حجم اه الدبلوماسي حيث ممكن تاثر في انهاء
الازمه السوريه
انا اتحدث بدقه عن موضوع المساعدات التي
ترد الى مصر يعني انت تقول انه ممكن اه اه
اه وقف هذه المساعدات او اتخاذ قرارات
بشانها من جانب الدبلوماسيه المصريه ولكن
الا يستتبع ذلك ايضا المشكله
ماذا قلت تحديدا يعني هل توافق اذا كان اه
اه وزير الخارجيه يقول انه يريد اعاده
النظر في هذه المساعدات الا يلوح الا يعني
هذا انه يلوح بقطع بقطع بعضها او بوقف
بعضها
لا لا اولا انا قلت هو نظام محافظ
استقرار
يغير مسار العلاقات الدوليه مجرد
هذه مجرد التلويح بانه قد يرفض بعض هذه
المعونات الا يستتبع ذلك ايضا اه اه يعني
مشاكل في العلاقات الثنائيه بين مصر ودول
تتلقى منها هذه المساعدات
التلميح مش قرار ممكن اقول اه عده اشارات
ورموز لكنها ليست قرار هذه نقطه مهمه اه
لكن ايضا هناك في امريكا اجهزه كثيره اه
تؤيد استمرار المعقوله وتنتقد اوباما
وبعدين زي ما قلت في الاول اوباما خاصه
الجوله الاولى مع مصر لانه يحاول الضغط
على الجيش معرفش ثاني حاجه ان هو حاول
يدخل الاخوان في مصالحه استخدموا العنف
معنا كل راح يكون محرج جدا امام الراي
العام الامريكي ازاء ح تدخل جماعه او حاله
المصالحه الوطنيه بشروط الاخوان فممكن
يكون بالفعل على لان امريكا فعلا خسر في
مفاوضاتها مع مصر والناس اخذوا ما انت لم
تتخذ قرار بشان
[تصفيق]
يعني رغم الشجب للعنف ورغم ما يقال ان
المعارضه حاليا او اه تحالف قوى الشرعيه
ومنها الاخوان المسلمون وهي فصيل منها
انهم ت عليه حاليا
اهم حاجه تقييم الموقف في ضوء قرار اتخذ
اللي حصل انه الاخوه زي ما ذكرت الاخوان
اللي عرفوا غير الشرعيه المصري ولا غير
غير ان موقف امريكي وبعدين المواجهه يعني
مش حيكون فيها اي تساهم في اصرار من قبل
الدوله انهم بيواجهوا الاخوان
حول الموقف الامريكي عندما اه اه مثلا اه
اه اوقفت المناورات العسكريه المشتركه
النجم الساطع
اه ممكن الى حد ما بس مش حيكون خساره
استراتيجيه ل ل مصر ولامريكا اه
هل هو قرار مصري ان قرار خارجي بوقف هذه
المساعدات الى مصر
القديمه الامريكان
يعني هذه الجماعه يعني نتكلم يقدم
والاحسان لا تقدم مساعده دون ان يكون لها
هدف الناحيه الثانيه المساعده الامريكيه
اللي هي مليار وثلاثه من عشره او مليار
ونص هذه كما كان بدافع ليست مساعده
التزامات بالنسبه ل كامب ديفيد التي تم
بين عناصر فيها هذه تم يعني لا نقول على
مساعده
كامب ديفيد واخلاء سينا والالتزامات
والتنسيق الامني مع اسرائيل ومع امريكا
ولا يمكن هذا النظام ان يعمل ما يجري في
مصر وهذا القتل وهذا يعني هذا الفكر الا
اذا كان مدعوم امريكيا واسرائيليا اعمل
ولا تخشى والباقي هذا كلها لا يجب ان نعلم
احنا نستقبل معونات لا يمكن ان تقدم معونه
الا اذا كان لها هدف او اذا كان عندك بديل
انا بسال ما هو البديل الذي يمكن ان
تعملوا مصر للاستغناء يقول لنا انا استغني
عن المظله الامريكيه
وعندي كذا
الدين ابدا انما هو بيتكلم كلام لا اساس
له
الا تعتقد انه يعني من اه اه الشكل الذي
تحدث به اه وزير الخارجيه المصري يعني
معلوم ان دبلوماسيه تستخدم لتقليل الضغوط
لتقريب العلاقات وجهات النظر هل رايت فعلا
انه كان ديبلوماسيا في حديثه
الى حد ما يعني ما عم خطا فادح التزم
بالمعايير وكان فيه اه لغه معينه بيتحدث
ها اه بس ممكن ايضا ويكون بحاجه يعني مثلا
ممكن يكون عارف انه روسيا مساعداتها في
دور دبلوماسي ناشط اكثر السعوديه
والامارات والكويت
عليه انه حيكون مثلا في تعاون اكثر مع
الصين في تعاون مع ايران حتى اوروبا اللي
تجد ان تستمر في معاونتها اما دول اوروبيه
يعني
الحقيقه انتو اجراءات تكلموا عن مساعدات
هذه يعني في الحقيقه نقطه
الشكل يعني هل يعتبر هل رايت انه كان
ديبلوماسيا بحيث فعليا يستخدم الدبلوماسيه
لتقليل الضغوط واه تقريب وجهات النظر
هذا انا هذا الكلام كله هناك يعني انت لو
لاحظت سيادتك انه في ثلاث اربعه ايام
الاخيره لانه النظام مكشوف وما عملوا من
جرائم مش امام العالم لا يمكن ان هم ما
يتعاملوا مع امام شعب فهو فيه اه اه اه
مستشار رئيس الجمهوريه يتكلم ومستشار
الرئيس ال وتكلم والنهار ده بيتكلم هذا
الشعور بالذنب اما ما مكفوفين ما حكى
ديبلوماسي انا متاكد لو امريكا اه ل اه
يعني
المرصد تعوا في الجامعه الامريكيه يتكلم
كويس
لك الدكتور محمد زكريا مطر الاستاذ
الجامعي والعضو في جبهه الضمير الوطنى
المصرى وكان ايضا معنا في هذه الحلقه من
واشنطن نبيل ميخائيل استاذ العلوم
السياسيه بجامعه جورج واشنطن اشكركم او
بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده
فيما وراء خبر جديد الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]